this is a thing because when I met you
you were broke so why aren't you
accustomed to that life because you were
broke for 24 years
and you've been Rich for 17 months so
how are you so accustomed
how did you acclimatize so quickly
[Music]
was a good guys what's good girls
we are inside sng
[Music]
you know the Vibes episode 219 I believe
yes sir uh and you are chilling we
demand them the crew the crew the boys
the guys the last the geezers and the
camps
those jokes guys Jay money and fire off
wings are here with you today yeah mum
um and guys if you enjoy being here with
us on a Monday please join us on a
Thursday so quickly just before we
continue pause the episode head on over
to patreon.com forward slash shits and
gigs and you're gonna join us every
Thursday you're going to be a true cult
baby thanks
and you go into
um I'm burping bro because I just next
an entire month so I think it was going
to give me energy but all it did is give
me indigestion
um
three pound a month 10p a day run the
Peter S and G and you're gonna join the
cult for real for real it's gonna be
chirps and things over there the chat is
chatting over there and you've got three
years worth of content to catch up on
facts so please head on over patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs and get
started today guys if you are watching
us on the U of tubes please like the
video if you like the video again chirps
are Ting in the comments we need the
breeding grounds okay for the SMG called
The Cult babies I'm heading over to Ohio
in the year 2020 three or four log cabin
in the woods and it's just going to be
Vibes white robes and Yeezys how many
being built
currently being planning permission has
been granted we already know the Vibes
um we've already got the influence we
just need the size and the use to
indoctrinate so we can go on for
generations to come
um so guys
subscribe to the channel notifications
on yeah man content is going to be
content in now yeah we're going to be
doing more and more and more a lot and
we want you guys to to see everything
okay and finally guys if you are
listening to us on Spotify or apple
podcast or wherever you like to listen
to podcasts please please please please
please please please please from the
bottom of a heart please leave a nice
review give us a style rating five is
preferable but feel how you want to feel
I don't want to tell you how to live
your life we are free thinking
individuals in this room and that's why
we are the second best podcast on the
planet folks guys without any further
wait do you even have a fun fact
it's the tragedies that you were going
to do that I said that's gonna be my fun
facts let's do trash news with fire lord
flakes let me give him his uh
introduction so guys this guy I've known
for 10 uh for 13 years 13 arduous years
guys when I met him he had a pathetic
little mustache and some weird thing on
his chin now he has the beard of beard
come on my comrade come on my silk sexy
tall dark and handsome
Fire Lord Flags
let's get into it before we get into it
random real quick yeah
how do you remember how old you were
when you realized that tall dog and
handsome didn't mean black
um that was that's actually one of my
tweets I've got on my toilet Fame I'll
swear yeah it was it was I'll come back
to it it's starting along the lines of
um it was only yesterday that I realized
when white people say tall dark and
handsome they meant Ben Affleck
bro when people say what's your type
tall dark and handsome I used to be like
less let's go the blacks are beloved
so obviously Everyone likes black guys
so but you meant Ben Affleck yeah but
you actually just meant brown hair yeah
how is that dark
dark
is dark don't enrage me don't enrage me
and none of it meant black none of it
none of it just white with brown hair
[ __ ] it hell that's dark oh you're black
yeah Joey that's a difference
wow that Affleck is too dark and
handsome you're black
laughs
wow
funny funny funny funny funny funny all
right trash news will you go for us uh
trash News slash fun fact of the day
Blac Chyna is the top earning crater on
only fans after making a whopping 20
million dollars per month in 2021.
in 2021 American model and television
personality Blac Chyna was the top
earning Creator on only fans with an
estimated 20 million dollars in blah
blah blah blah actress and Creator Bella
Thorne ranked second with an estimated
11 million US dollars per month and
rapper cardi B with 9.3 million US
dollars in revenues on only fans
I don't I can't it's bad baby not in
there either because I thought she raked
it in I think that was maybe the year
before that could have been 2020. badly
bad baby's only like 19. oh yeah yeah
true it was last it was last year it was
definitely lost yeah she racked up she
did rack up I think hers was like a I
think hers was like a smaller period of
time maybe might have been like in a day
or a week or something like that maybe
maybe but she did yeah that was yeah
that was a bit gross when we read that
out yeah yeah she's a huge he's a you
yeah I don't know yeah but hey bag is
the bag is a bag bag is a bag is a bag
but 20 M's a month I just can't believe
that I'll tell you why I can't believe
it because she's wearing headgear
sparring yeah Yachts yeah exactly she's
she's a liar she's a liar and a cheat so
let's address the real situation here
what
what lies are they spinning and why are
they spending these lies I don't know
what connection she has with the head of
only fans to the point where her people
can talk to his people and be like look
we need an influx here yeah so like I
don't know what kind of deal we can
patent but we're gonna say some [ __ ]
yeah and we need you to not deny it yeah
we're gonna say something outlandish
[ __ ] we need you to back it and stay
quiet yeah just I'm not asking you to
lie yeah just shut up by shutting the
[ __ ] up means you're back in it and
that's okay with me because we need to
say that Blac Chyna is the highest
earner because Blac Chyna is butters for
one for one
for two she's old as deck for two for
three she scraps [ __ ] in in boxing
Rings bro that was the what I I you talk
about it probably like two months ago it
was one of the worst things I've ever
seen it was literally the most horrific
Scene It was just silicon chicken yeah
and it was just the softest punches
we've seen and their temples starting it
wasn't she I'm expecting to believe
she's making 20 M's a month only fans
impossible so she's making what 240
million a year impossible
240 million a year are you a Kardashian
what on on you're telling me in five
years she's gonna be a billionaire it's
impossible that's impossible because
there she's not relevant yeah bro she's
not right like any bread no disrespect
Herbert but you're not relevant like
it's you're just not I just feel like
like you said it was an outlandish
statement they told someone one of her
peoples told one of the only fans
peoples listen we're gonna say some [ __ ]
chill just firm it for a bit
I need to be relevant again because
clearly the boxing thing I did a few
months ago yeah wasn't getting a
destruction tick over the way we thought
he would what I thought was gonna happen
was
Blac Chyna we get another tick white
thing we're fighting in a ring traction
we're gonna start our own female YouTube
boxing thing oil and friction and
friction this is sexy yeah yeah that
traction only fans we've got a new thing
for you clearly it was the least sexy
thing I've ever seen oh bro it was the
least sexy thing I've seen it probably
got one view which was me yeah you know
I mean because I had to show it on here
and it was it was shocking it was
actually shocking so the fact that
people are trying to say or she's trying
to say she's earning 20 M's a month show
me the receipts show us all the results
literally you are such a liar it
actually doesn't bode well with your
your deals your morals your brand you've
got two kids to look after you're out
here lying like this yes
unfair on uh tiger and it's unfair on
Rob Kardashian because they don't need
that you're not seeing child support
from me yeah
you think a tiger ain't bringing into it
neither tiger nor rubber bringing
anywhere near that anywhere near you're
not seeing nothing from me in fact pay
me something run me my emotional support
man because you've put me through the
ringer bro
Bella Thorn I heard was making racks I
heard she was making racks on there as
well I can't remember how much robs you
said it there but I can't remember at
the time hers was like a million in the
first day she went on there yes yes
crazy mad that's crazy cardi B I can see
where she makes tracks because he
couldn't I can definitely see I would be
so intrigued to see what's going on over
there cardi B's up in there dude why
what exactly but the thing is
um only fans wasn't intentionally or
originally made for explicit content it
was just made for Content yeah so
like that's why I feel like that's why
um not I feel like but musicians around
there as well I feel like um tigers on
there I think tigers on their slinging
dick bro there are other there are other
musicians on there that aren't that I've
heard that aren't
just doing sexual [ __ ] they're just on
there yeah but they I think a lot of the
time to be fake yes you are right but I
don't think they went on there through
their own fruition I think only fans
paid them to go on there ah true true
I'm not fall back that way because
Michael B Jordan was on there before and
I know for a fact he's not slinging dick
on there Michael Jordan Michael B Jordan
ain't yeah running yeah dick print on on
only fans no so he's not gonna get any
more movies and what's he even what
content does anyone even want to see
from Michael bought unless it is Dick
Brent yeah ain't no one trying to see
nothing that's weird man
that is very weird but
obviously this is this this
um what's it um what's her name Blac
Chyna is Blac Chyna thing obviously
isn't true yeah but
would you
if I I I feel like you're gonna ask me
something and if 20 ends is at the end
of it if this if the sentence you're
about to ask me ends in for 20 million a
month the answer is yes that's not what
I was going to ask you cool but I was
going to say
if this failed God forbid God forbid if
this podcast failed and
you couldn't because obviously you've
got the neck tattoo now remember yeah
yeah this is I'm not working for another
[ __ ] again yeah yeah or another [ __ ]
regenta yeah you can't get an office job
yeah oh no PT's hiring you no Jim's
hiring you
you need to feed you need to hunt you
need something and you think [ __ ] it
only fans what would you what kind of
what's the limit what content would you
not do
I would not involve another bra okay
but I'd probably do a little plug talk
thing you know what plug talk is
the the podcast yeah what was it no
jumper no jumper is misses and leaning
of the plug yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that they're great
they've got it so bad and you know what
I hate I saw a clip of it on PornHub on
my general scrolling and I saw it and I
was like oh let me actually see you yeah
and then I saw I had them banging this
yeah and he's got his little pot belly
and his his pipe is not even piping and
I'm like
he's literally got everything patterned
um but I will try a little plug talk 2.0
okay how would you patent that what
would you
just
just
blacked okay
black to talk okay
flagged talk okay yeah or caramel convos
yeah let's go let's go galaxy yay
caramel convoys and then I would just
have fireplaces everywhere and carpets
yeah I know there's bear carpet there's
bear rugs biscuit rug that's it Red Room
yeah red lighting yeah yeah yeah night
mode yeah you're envisioning the whole
thing night mode
um fire three fireplaces
yeah yeah night mode yeah three
fireplaces yeah
a bear rug oh and just me
just oil done oiled yeah and then I'm
laying like this
with a porn star and we're just talking
intently
um and my I set the mic to just drop me
a few decibels yeah yeah and I just
listen I [ __ ] yeah listen yeah yeah
like caramel convos yeah
um
I understand and we're not even talking
sexy [ __ ] it's just generally
we're getting deep this is the side to
the pornstar no one's ever seen before
and then we lips
passionately okay okay and then like I I
say uh I I go I go and this is this is
the end of the segment uh this is at the
end of every conversation
um we ask our guests to find it in their
heart to show me the love that
our audience has for you and I'll say
kiss me like you love me
kiss me like you love me Lena the plug
Asa Akira kiss me like you love me
and then I just get my fingers
and everyone's like oh oh [ __ ] oh this
Scott therefore yeah
your boy's viral yay viral your inbox
will be
BR get me on the show run me on the show
get me on caramel compost caramel convos
I need that I need that and you know
your boy's got that heavy dick
so once they actually see it they're
like raw
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo [ __ ] that was funny
[Laughter]
yeah that's how I'd have to patent it oh
[ __ ]
but like
but while I'm building that audience
yeah I'm struggling yeah you're you're
I'm struggling you're [ __ ] anything
yeah yeah you know anything I've got a
few guests are gonna be tragic oh
they're going to be bottled at a barrel
porn star yeah porn stars that aren't
even mainstream not even mainstream yeah
and amateur they
the first season of caramel convos yeah
these men think this love lips is a dare
because these things are just yeah
they're just not walking yeah yeah
hepatitis things
happy Seas we just got happy Seas up in
there oh my God scar tissue and
hepatitis oh my God and they're like
he's not gonna lip so like he loves her
surely and at the end of every episode
he will I lips the [ __ ] out of them oh
my God and they're like raw and then we
start building audience and all it takes
is one painting it does all it takes is
one bangers and then an Elixir and then
my Subs are through the roof say less
how much how much would you charge at
the minimum only fans
um satin I charge enough
I think I charged like seven pound a
month okay it's not we're not throwing
the content away we're not just giving
it away yeah you gotta pay for it yeah
but it's not top tier it's not too much
it's not too much not too much it's not
too much because at the end of the day
like you're starting to talk Brands only
fans like what what even is this yeah
what are you looking for yeah what are
we actually looking for but then once
they tune in and just they're just
hearing like the crackle of wood burning
true and you just see a glass of wine
I'm just swimming red and there's just a
thing giggling
giggling
and that ellipses again yeah yeah yeah
and I every every 15 minutes I just get
a little bit closer to her a little bit
closer anything can he's gonna lipstick
[ __ ] [ __ ] lips
[ __ ] where is he gonna live sir bro they
were there that's Jones Banger that's
jokes Banger and then they can't believe
how quick I know
that's the Bollywood
[Laughter]
I wasn't expecting to say that that's
the twist in the shot yeah that's the
bit that when you when the guest comes
in that's kind of NDA yeah yeah yeah
have to say NDA enters you're not
allowed to tell anyone how fast he nuts
yeah because it needs to be a surprise
yeah yeah
Sensual You lips mean like you love me
you get throat banged
everything is thinking they're thinking
is this porn or is this actual love yeah
yeah because I'm here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then I they think
they see the heavy dick
and in fact I just banged and then I
just pull out I'm like I've got one and
she gossed yeah yeah I pull out and she
thinks what are you doing what are you
doing and she looks and lives soft
[Music]
soaked
ah
oh god oh damn
and they're like now what the [ __ ] and
then all the lights turn on and then the
producer just washes around oh thanks
for that and I'm like guys that was
episode 16 of Paramount Converse tune in
next week we've got this guest Lisa
Ann's up in here oh my dear Dad she
won't believe how fast I know
stay tuned stay tuned see you next week
and I've just got juice just Tropicana I
know just or a cap or something I'm
squeezing it she would believe she won't
believe how fast I'm not
I had to just face
[Laughter]
funniest scenario ever
yeah boy oh my goodness that's hilarious
yeah fam that's what I do I'm sure I I
don't know I might do that because I
mean imagine
this sounds like money bro you're you're
apart from the
five second not your satisfying women
you're sitting there they're in a
bathroom yeah candles lit fire going you
got this rug they've got red wine on top
white one whichever one they prefer yeah
whatever you want you got it I'm
listening to you yeah oh I'm listening
listening to you and I'm giving it back
yeah I give you advice I'm giving you
everything your man down I'm repeating
what you're saying word is different to
make it seem like I give a [ __ ] bro yeah
bro yeah I'm just spit and spit and
spitting and then I get closer and
closer and closer and then you pause you
turn to the camera
now the part of the show
that you've all been waiting for
you lick your lips
you swallow spit
The Crowd Goes Wild yeah everyone's
listening to everyone's intense he's
like even though the audio list is like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah yeah is
it still playing
you look at your phone
but you hear the crackling in the
background so you know
yeah so mommy you've been waiting for
him lick your lips swallow spit and you
grab her you grab the back of her head
you scrunch it
bring her clothes and you just lips lips
deeply deep that's what it you know the
lips from um what Michael Jackson video
is that um
where they're in Egypt
and that she's got the do you remember
the time at the time and your lips are
her neck falls back like this oh yeah
fam she's lips and her neck just drips
back because she's engulfed in it you
and me that's one of my favorite Michael
Jackson videos and songs yeah bro Eddie
Murphy in there yeah yeah but back to
the point back to the point yeah lips
are her neck droops back droops all the
way she's in golf and usually like
now it's time
[Music]
oh my gosh oh my and then you tell her
get comfortable get comfortable it's
gonna be all right get whichever
position you want get comfortable if I'm
she scarries to get a [ __ ] she's
scariest
eye contact once
just
oh dear one pump I'm squeezing the traps
here
Jesus
straight to the camera
oh God guys thank you very much that was
episode seven of caramel convos
with Asa Akira next week we've got Sarah
J
she won't believe how fast
black genius
that's the funniest thing we've said on
this show I promise you oh my God that
was hilarious yeah bro [ __ ] me camera
combos is is a thing I might have to TM
that before before I see I was not after
causing lawsuits
that is yeah that's the one [ __ ]
that's the ticket that's the ticket
right I've got trash news I hit me it's
this um
you see this Ray J thing all right see
the thing is right I'll say my piece and
I'll let you get get onto this right
yeah I've seen the rage 18 but I've not
seen the Ray J team because I've seen it
pop up I've seen obviously it's getting
more traction about how Chris made him
do it and blah blah blah signed
different three different things or he
had three different videos but
I've not invested any time to like
actually watch the video I've seen like
little Snippets like big man we're
talking about something that happened
what 15 16 17 years ago yeah
gives a [ __ ] like why now again yeah
it's like they revived this every other
year literally what's the point
literally bro like
I was hoping he was done with this noise
when he released his earbuds what it
called I forgot about those what are the
raycons
these [ __ ] raycons and he had all the
YouTubers promo in his Recons I think
Ray J's making money here and maybe he's
done with this foolishness because he's
been bitter for years yes bro yeah it's
been so long she slopped your top on
camera time oh God drop it it's the
deadest thing it's in black and white
this is dead bro stop it
banking there was no HD there was none
back in there it was dead bro Pete Davis
and Bank concussion this is leave it bro
there's literally other Kim Kardashian
news on right now like that who cares
yeah literally who cares but um yeah so
basically
basically something happened where Chris
Jenner went on a TV show I can't
remember what it was it was like James
cordless it was on Saturn but basically
she took a lie detector test okay with
some Bray and one of the questions was
something to do with did you have
anything to do with uh the release of
the sex tape and on a lie detector says
she said no and he came back as true
okay whereas Ray J's got receipts so Ray
J got Vex who cares don't know why hey
okay he got Vex and was like my goal is
going on National Television on a lie
detector test lion and she he basically
exposed the doctor that she used to take
the test as uh or doctor or whatever the
technician or whoever took the test yeah
has like is like some fraud stuff like
renowned fraudster so he exposed him for
being a fraudster okay I was like oh he
had his private investigators license
taken off him he's had this he's like
that like this guy is a liar and this
whole polygraph test was a fix and I'm
gonna prove it to you because here are
documents with my signature on it Kim's
signature on it and it uh it was Chris's
idea for us to release a sex tape and
she made us do it in three different
locations three times across three
different locations and she would pick
the best one yeah that she thought would
go most viral and then she released and
she sold it
and I've got all the receipts yeah and
he was actually just showing contracts
and all that stuff the thing with my man
is he ruined it he could have kept it
down to a two minute insta life yeah I
feels like seven minutes or so it was
like 35 minutes he's rambling yeah I
think the snipper I saw on Twitter was
seven minutes but I didn't click the
video yeah bro he's Ram Bo okay rambling
there's one point where [ __ ] like bug
or a moth like went on his phone or his
face he was chatting about it for like
four minutes like what was that what
even was that and you're like big man
get to the point oh my God goodness Ray
J drop it you're embarrassing yourself
embarrassing you're in embarrassing
yourself yeah that's um
it's just what's that like
I just don't understand why he would
continue to do that to his own name now
he's tarnishing himself yeah because he
realized he doesn't have a name
he has nothing but this now true your
Brandy's brother and you [ __ ] Kim
Kardashian on camera that's all you've
got true and we thought we thought that
the raycons were a scapegoat but you're
still in this do you remember the
glasses he brought I said they're
indestructible
I don't want to chat by this guy this
guy's a fool this guy's a fool like he's
actual a fool and like it's mad that
like he seems like the guy who was
either gonna be an artist
or a Nickelodeon actor
he was gonna be like Kell yeah yeah or
Arnez
yeah from one on one from one on one
yeah or [ __ ] homeboy from nasso Raven
the bread yes yes
he's won a dead man oh Ness
he's moving like this man but he just
happens to be a singer yeah so these
people just let him get away with it but
you're you're Nickelodeon Brett he is on
Nickelodeon nickel you're a drinking
Josh [ __ ] that's what you are that's
because you just chat [ __ ] he if he
literally had one wish he would want all
of these dreams to come true because he
is begging him oh he's begging it he's
big he's been begging it um but like the
only reason people were interested is
because
one people think that that he's
narcissistic enough to believe that this
thing's going viral because people
actually give a [ __ ] about Ray J people
are actually just interested because it
proves that home goal literally hauled
out her own daughter facts literally
horde watched three videos of her own
flesh and blood sucking dick
and then sold it pick the best one and
then and then sold it and then that's
for their family that's how their family
was made yeah that's the dynasty the
dead dad and her sucking dick on camera
that is the Kardashian Legacy and that's
why they're one of the [ __ ] they are
the most famous family on planet Earth
all because their dad wrapped OJ and the
daughter sucked dick on camera that is
why they are who they are that's why
[ __ ] Kylie is a billionaire yeah all
because of that yeah that's why their
dad is a [ __ ] woman of the year yeah
yeah all because of that yeah that's why
your sister stays getting cheated on you
oh my God yeah remains cheated on yeah
because of that all of you man are caked
and Rich and Famous and have everything
in the world Chloe will never learn yeah
no matter how much lipo and surgery you
have Chloe don't rape you they see you
as the female Rob
[Music]
and Courtney's just stush
pain and spanking just don't have this
hiding yeah yeah yeah she's so pain and
stuff she's not freeing it up like yeah
like the sisters of marriage yeah and
boredom they're not Freedom board you're
not freeing up like your sisters I don't
want you yeah yeah get some surgery yeah
yeah entertain me where's the Silicon
now silicon and sloppy top that's what
we were promised hilarious Peter just
added with use and responsibilities yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't need that yeah so
they just run to Chloe boy and she gives
them the world and they laugh and
they're like that was so easy
[Music]
Johnny that was so easy that I'm
probably gonna run it back yeah yeah
that was so incredibly easy
I'm a catch a jet to Mykonos now from
here yeah order me an Uber now I've got
hoes to see because this was
embarrassingly easy yeah it was it was
too easy and I'm don't I genuinely don't
give a [ __ ] about being caught in
Mykonos with next gal because I actually
like this one yeah I mean she's not
something she's actually banging and I
see myself of this one whereas for you
yeah you've forgiven me how many times
now bro the only time the public see you
and I together is on TMZ facts with a
little in the middle that's it
heartbreak every time anyone sees us
together but they see me with [ __ ] I
love all the time so let's just leave it
let's leave it and she actually does
leave it to be fair she just gets on
with her life and just sees the abuse
and cries and continues I have to rate
her to be fair but she doesn't learn
um the thing is I don't know what else
there is to learn yeah because she
patterns men yes you know what I mean
she grew up as an ugly fat sister yeah
and she patents men yeah yeah so she's
probably just like bro Karma [ __ ] Karma
I deal with men yeah and I get treated
yeah like so yeah yeah I get treated as
such fair I hear you so if I don't want
to get treated like this I should get
with someone who's not gonna who's gonna
be gas to be with me there's plenty of
man out there but they're not male men
they're not NFL players they're not
basketball players facts facts tis
what's his bro game of the game game is
the game that was funny
um
right have you got something or I've got
uh you tell me how come I've got an am I
the [ __ ] oh hit me yeah let's go and
then you've got some trash news yes
right so am I the [ __ ]
this is a very sexual episode today
I'm a woman and I have a high sex drive
okay I've been with my husband since I
was 19.
and we've been together 16 years
16 years
[ __ ] man we had a kid when I was 22.
and then three more all two years apart
so they've got four use yeah
18 years from 20 to
what 30. Jesus I spent all of my 20s
pregnant and nursing I'm now 35.
I have found myself and what I like when
it comes to sex and it could have been
and it couldn't have been more opposite
than my husband he wants little to
nothing to do with me and turns me down
90 of the time Jesus he's banging
someone else Sam let's continue
I've believed for the last 12 years that
it was all my fault I'm too fat I'm not
pretty enough I've got stretch marks
he's also called me big and led me to
believe this
finally we're in therapy only to find
out he's asexual and it has nothing to
do with me oh I've been in therapy for
six years because I've hated myself for
so long assuming he wouldn't bang me uh
because of me mind you I tried to be
sexy I asked for an open marriage and he
said [ __ ] no
she said I wanna cheat bad
I wanna cheat bad oh my God I also want
to stay married because we've got four
kids and a really great relationship but
a lot of the time it's like we're
roommates he hasn't gotten me off in
five plus years
I give him head every time in effort to
get him to have more sex I've done
Boudoir picks I've told him exactly what
I want and I've begged him to go down I
begged him to go down to me nah nothing
nah
he doesn't matter
um he doesn't matter age what it doesn't
matter
I don't know what that means
um I think he doesn't want or need sex
and I need it like my next breath if I
cheat it could ruin my life and my kid's
life if I don't I will continue to never
have my needs met I'm either [ __ ] for
wanting to yeah basically am I an ass
off who went into nut with someone other
than my husband or my vibrator
oh bro wow oh so recap they've been
together basically forever yeah they've
got four kids and she spent all of her
20s either popping out Utes or giving
them milk yeah
she's at the point now where they
haven't uh had a ute in five years
but it's basically a bread drinking he
never wants to bang should give him
slots relentlessly in order to get
something going and he just said no no
no no no
90 of the time he says stop ten percent
of the time he's like fine
literally fine [ __ ] sake because I
just don't want to argue yeah oh my God
they've been in therapy she thinks it's
all because of her she thinks she's fat
and ugly and and he just doesn't want
nothing to do with it
he's gone to the therapist and says it's
not even hurting I just don't like sex
period
I never get horny and she's like raw
okay so it's not to do with me I love
him he loves me he's just not about this
sex game and
um
I need something so I turned to him and
said big man no offense if you're not
about this sex game and I am let's try
and open marriage team yeah I want to be
with you I love our family I love our
kids
but I just need to nut so let me just
grab a nut and then we'll just carry on
man says are you literally crazy
are you literally crazy if I'm not nine
no one's nine
that's what marriage is yeah death do us
yeah literally sickness and health
Better or Worse death to us this is
worse and we're still yeah it's the
worst and this is a sickness
you're going to stay with me and you're
going to stay with me until one of us is
dead
open marriage my ass my ass
um so she's like raw selfish facts so
she's like the only way I'm doing it if
I sneak off and just get banged
but if I get caught
lost so is she the [ __ ] for thinking
of cheating or is she also for wanting
to cheat wanting to
I mean
it's very double-edged in my opinion
because I don't necessarily think she's
the [ __ ] for wanting to go to go and
she because I feel like any human in
that given situation would want to cheat
like if I'm with an asexual partner
and I know I'm a horny mess I'm gonna
want to cheat whether I do or not as a
separate thing but me thinking about
wanting to cheat and it's not even the
fact that I'm not trying with my partner
I've I've
gone down on her plethora of times
I've begged her she says yeah she says
yuck yuck yeah actually that repulses me
stop it
or else yeah I'm like
[ __ ] sake what more can I do I can't
keep using this flashlight yeah I can't
keep using this flashlight I need the
real thing yeah any walls either you let
me Smash
or I'm gonna smash you which one is it
yeah it says no to an open marriage
bro you can't
I wouldn't blame her if she actually
cheered I'm not saying she should do it
but because of the fact that
right they've got four kids together so
clearly she was or they were very
sexually active maybe the point at a
point maybe yeah maybe because it takes
one time to get pregnant yeah over the
course of eight years so maybe they
weren't that sexually active but they
were active to a point where they could
have sex and not have sex have kids
multiple times so clearly there was a
time it works it worked clearly there
was a time he was down but also
considering they went to therapy and
he's now said oh it's actually not you
I'm just very much asexual for me sex
does nothing for me I can't really get
hard blah blah blah blah so what is
giving head talk I don't really
understand if I don't really understand
where that's leading to if she's giving
him head and he's obviously biologically
he's going to get hard because it's
natural but mentally it's doing nothing
for you this is you he's doing nothing
it's just a tool yeah it's literally
just a tool yeah yeah so I wouldn't
blame her for cheating on him
but he's also very very very very very
selfish to say no to an open marriage
considering this is a marriage here this
is a give and take like regardless of
whether you're Ace or I'm asexual in
this scenario I should be able to be
like okay I'm asexual I'm literally
turning you down not because of you but
because of me you should be able to well
I should be able to understand why you
want to step out just for one specific
thing but then come back to our marital
home because I'm not providing what I
should be providing regardless of death
do us part and all this stuff it's a
two-way street
it has it has to be a mutual playing
field so it's very selfish on his part
so I don't necessarily think she is the
[ __ ] for wanting to cheat because at
the end of the day we're human beings
we're organisms every organism wants to
not it's natural is it in my head bro I
don't even call it cheating you're not
doing it yeah at this point because like
you're not even playing the game yeah so
how can I be cheating because you're not
even playing yeah you're not even you
leave it on the pitch you're not on the
pitch you're not on the pitch you're not
even on the subs bench you're nowhere
near this game it's literally like me
being with a girl and being like I love
the cinema that's a massive part of my
life I [ __ ] love the cinema and she's
like gang all right cool like well I
[ __ ] hate this Cinema so let's not do
that and I'm like I bet well that's fine
I'll just go Cinema and you stay at home
and she's like excuse me
no we were both going Cinema or no one's
going to cinema and I'm like it comes
into my dad she's like no I hate the
cinema that's your problem I'm going
that's your problem yeah you literally
cannot be vaccinated yeah yeah I'm going
yeah why are you talking about you're a
crazy person you're actually crazy
you're literally crazy I'm [ __ ] going
and it's the same thing I remember I had
this conversation with a girlfriend of
mine when I was like 17 18. she's very
religious and she turned around to me
one day and she was like
I'm thinking about being celibate and I
was like gang like we're obviously done
yeah you know what I mean I was like
obviously we're not together then she
was like wow she was so shocked she was
like yeah wow are you [ __ ] seriously
like you that shallow and I was like
shadow
this is what we do yeah this is what
we're here for this is what we're here
for like if you turned around to me the
day we met and was like by the way I'm
celibate we never would have got to this
one fact you don't get to change the
rules yeah while we're here yeah and
expect me to just go along with it yeah
I was like it's fine like I can respect
your views I respect your religion if
you want to be celibate it's absolutely
fine I'm not even upset but we're not
together yeah facts it's literally
that's literally it she was like wow
like wow so the only way you'll stay
with me is if I actually go against my
beliefs and like sleep with you and I'm
like
whoa like what do you want me to say no
if you don't want to I don't want you to
but big man you're changing the rules
yeah and it's not cheating if you're not
playing yeah if you are not playing it's
not cheating so I'm doing it facts like
regardless how you feel about I can see
why I can see why you'll be upset but
like then play yeah yeah yeah literally
play like it's it's as simple as that
it's one of them but yeah I can see why
it's a it's a tricky one but like you're
gonna have to just tell him big man
like I said if you're not on the pitch
I'm not cheating facts if you're not
willing to play then what's the problem
just just want just because you don't
want to have sex with his life that
means you're literally saying I'm not
allowed to have this for the rest of my
life that's what you're saying look
after the kids this weekend I'm out yeah
look after the kids this weekend because
I am out with my gal yeah wrecked and
I'm gonna I'm gonna be out fortnightly
Fortnight I'm gonna be staying out
overnight because ultimately getting
piped because that's what I need to
survive that's what that's what I need
and you don't want to play and that's
literally fine so there's literally no
hard feelings and I'm telling you I
didn't even want to break up big man I
want to be I want to be here I love what
we have but I love our kids I love our
Dynamic I love all of it banging bro the
jokes are sick or the tickle fights
everything bro just like the family
occasions the barbecues no one Cooks a
steak like you big man come on it's the
[ __ ] I love it I love when we binge
Grace Anatomy together I just live for
it and you make my cup of T just right
bro the massages everything is perfect
but you're not banging me so I'm just
literally he can have one like I don't
even see his face I just need a pipe
that's all I need so I need and I'll be
back don't even think about it that's it
you're making up you're making a man out
of a mile hill that's it just let me
bang
do your thing mum yes you're not
cheating so just do it do your thing do
your thing right guys give us
a little little little little bit of
your time just so we can keep the lights
on and tell you guys how to stay Ultra
smooth [ __ ] with the boys and girls
over at mascape they've brought to you
guys the next level of male grooming
we're talking the ultra smooth package
guys okay now the ultra smooth package
is a specialized groin shave and quit
kit to help you buff protect and smooth
your most sensitive errors okay we're
talking the crop shaver razor the crop
exfoliator and the crop gel okay guys
you no longer have to borrow your ladies
razor for that precise trim okay guys we
will know how hard it is you get you put
blade to skin you get Pops that two
blade thing as well
you get bumps and ink bones we don't
like to see that we're not here for that
guys so you need that smooth smooth yeah
Ultra smooth okay guys so if you
live in Europe
if you live in Europe you live in the
states guys
Ultra smooth package that's the one for
you all you need to do is go to
maskscape.com and if you want 20 off and
free shipping use the code sng Sierra
November golf that's manscape.com guys
the code is sng Sierra November Golf and
let's get back to the episode thank you
very much
um I've got a trash news
yeah lady breaks up with her boyfriend
and takes 3.6 million lottery Fortune
after living with him rent free I've
seen this one
39 year old Kirk Stevens was met with a
nasty shock after his live-in golfer and
won the lottery broke up with him and
cut him off the fortune Laura Hoyle
lived with Kirk rent-free and and they
came up with it the idea that instead
she would pay 25 a week into the
national lottery they won a whopping 3.6
M's in a set for life draw which pays
out 10 bags a month for 30 years
Laura was giving Kirk a grander month uh
sorry yeah Laura was giving Kirk a
thousand caught every month and they
also set up a joint account as Ghost
Hunters 18 months
18 months later
18 months later Kirk says that Laura
told him their relationship had gone
downhill and she wants it out when he
said what about our Lottery Win she said
it's not ours it's mine
I mean I read I actually did read this
one when I saw it and like
regardless of what like the title
portrays I feel like she's within a race
I the thing is I when I read The Heading
I was thinking oh this is going to be
just arguments when as soon as well I'll
let you finish anyway continue so yeah
like
I was gonna say
as long as she pays him the rent that he
was living in that that the rent like
obviously she wasn't paying rent
but she was paying 25 a week into the
national lottery which is a lot to put
in no wonder they won five a week 25 a
week into the national lotteries what
two pounds something like that a pound
lot of money a week no wonder you won
so then they won 3.6 million yeah and it
comes out every month in 10 bags oh
that's gonna last for ages ages [ __ ]
hell 10 bags a month for 30 years
that's decent also just run me the mint
three mil because the interest is going
to be juicy [ __ ] your 10 bags let me
slap that in the bank
and next month I will probably have
another one I can live off the interest
for a long time for more than 30 years
and still keep my 3.6 you teeth and
bastard why are you being slush also I
can see why they do it like that because
they set up a ghost hunting business
yeah so this is why you can't be trusted
with the 3.6 because you'll piss it away
this is why we have to give you 10 bags
yeah a [ __ ] month because you can't
be trusted Ghost Hunters Ghost Hunters
anyway as long as she paid him back what
the rent was her half of the rent for
however the year and a half there was 18
months so
um let's say his rent from the sounds of
it no offense doesn't sound like they
were living in a lavish yard yeah let's
say their rent is a grand a month as
long as she makes up 600 pounds
there's evens Even Stevens you're Even
Stevens and it sounds like she was given
a grand a month so she's more than even
as long as she yeah as long as she
um hit up
well she actually was it did I say 600
pounds yeah yeah was this 106 Grand six
grand sorry not 600 six [ __ ] Grand
six grand
as long as yeah then
we're calm
what are we doing here
I the thing is I completely agree like
well not even six round I must say 18 18
months
18 months yeah nine grand so she owes
him nine grand wait what what math are
you doing I'm sorry so hey sorry his
rent is let's say he's got a grand a
month yes for 18 months yes that's 18
Grand yes half of that is nine it's nine
grand she owes him nine grand okay I was
thinking what map group sorry he went
six I went six years because I was just
saying yeah yeah yeah you were allowing
me to just run away with foolish I was
just saying yeah yeah you were changing
numbers
she owes him nine grand 600 pounds what
the [ __ ] what what what's going on 600
nine grand yeah nine grand so as long as
you pay them that that thing nine times
which I doubt she did
um yeah write me my nine grand yeah
that's all I want to know run me my nine
grand and then you can [ __ ] off with
your money because you'll ruin your
rights it's tough um it's always it's
annoying because he in the back of his
mind he's probably thinking [ __ ] why did
I why did I make her live rent free and
just pay for this [ __ ] I wish should
have both been contributing like he's
going to have so many regrets on blah
blah
yeah also though one thing I will say
about that that is a little bit of a
Twist I just cut you off by the way
sorry it's very rude
on second thoughts I can see why it
would be a piss take
because at the same time
I'm letting you live here rent free
regardless if you're spending a hundred
pound a month on the lottery yeah yeah
you'll live in rent free you I'm looking
after you yeah yeah and this is how
you're repairing me compensation somehow
please so run me my nine grand yeah
starting something to make me smile yeah
because you've got you're getting 10
bags a month Banks 10 bags a month every
month for 30 years yes you're gonna be
all right well I mean my nine grand that
you owe me
plus a little something to wet my beak
something something to make me feel like
what I did for you was appreciated facts
and then [ __ ] off facts you can do what
the you can do what you want with the
rest of the money for the rest of your
life yeah yeah yeah but I feel like I
deserve some oh sucks so I can
understand frustration this is why as
well
we need [ __ ] in writing oh facts we need
[ __ ] in writing we need [ __ ] writing
because like people get so like
put off by when especially when you're
discussing money and contracts and all
this stuff and people are like oh she's
not that kind of person he's not that
kind of person we don't need contracts
but when you're talking about
relationships bro let's just get the
context out the way you won the lottery
3.6 million you're going to be making 10
bags a month you're running me what a
bag a month say less for how long the
Whole 30 years right the Whole 30 years
right yeah because we love each other
right yeah cool here's a contract not in
heavy yeah all I'm asking is that you
say you sign and says you're just going
to give me a bag a month for as long for
the next 30 Years
I'm what I'm saying is I let you live
here rent free and I don't want to feel
hard done by it because you are within
your rights to take the money and take
yourself take the money and [ __ ] off and
leave me here when we both know we're in
the in this relationship we're in
agreement that's our money because the
only way you're able to afford that
thing is because I let you live here for
free yeah [ __ ]
out of your 10 bucks your boy wants one
what a million asking for one I'm not
asking for a lot run me one
sign the contract
push it away oh my gosh if you love me
if you don't sign it I know it's not
really real
I literally know it's not real and I'm
on Instagram live
I'm on Instagram live so my 76 followers
of Ghost Hunt Fanatics well no you're a
scandalous [ __ ] signed a thing when
Instagram live as we speak
because man don't need accountability
yeah that's jokes but yeah people hate
signing contracts boy single like
prenups prenups you pissed me off we've
had a couple prenup discussions I don't
have it on the Pod but we've had we've
had cleanup discussions oh yeah yeah I
love the idea of prenups I just well I
don't love the idea of products but I
just love the discussion around prenups
because I never understand
why someone wouldn't sign it because
it's like um how do I explain like
unless like it's exactly the same thing
so if
like I said the only reason you were
able to get this money the only reason
you had a spare hundred pound a month to
waste on lottery tickets is because you
were saving money by living in my yard
rent free rent free I did that for you
you would never be able to get that
money if it wasn't for me yep so you owe
me yep contract yep
same thing with a prenup if I was
married and I bought a prenup to someone
I was like I want you to sign it or if I
was going to get married I brought a
peanut I never said to me hang on
the only reason you were able to make
this business and make this money was
because the whole time
I was at yard looking after your use
because if I was not here
how are you recording these podcasts
please yeah yeah yeah yeah how are you
doing all this stuff yeah how are you
who was supporting you yeah when you
were doing all this because I remember a
time yeah I remember a time when you had
four downloads a week yeah
yeah and you needed Crepes
and you're hosing yourself that's what I
remember yeah so who patented you so how
was that working
about prenup yeah that's what I thought
yeah but on the other side if you
actually objectively take the
um timeline from when someone started a
business to when they're successful in
the business and then if you take that
person
and take them out of it and be like
objectively speaking could this person
get from A to B without this person if
the answer is yes sign it [ __ ] sign
it sign it literally sign it yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah and even if I agree
bro I'll buy you a whip and I'll buy you
a yard and go yeah sign here yeah yeah
and especially when you met me if
especially if you meet me when I'm cake
yeah oh yeah sign it you're signing it
when people oh bro when people get
married and they meet the person when
they're caked and they refuse to sign a
prenup how that isn't the biggest red
flag that's a huge red flag for me how
that isn't the biggest red flag it's
terrifying because at the end of the day
if if I love you if I'm willing to or we
are willing to marry each other I'm
clearly stating that I'm gonna look
after you regardless I'm I'm a giver
anyway yeah regardless don't you now
dare think that if anything God Fitbit
happens and you want to divorce me I
want to divorce you that you're going to
take half of our business yeah and you
had nothing to do with yeah contribute
to I just met you you've lost your mind
yeah you're out of control and like
control you're literally power drunk
yeah and it's not making sense yes this
isn't the woman I fell in love with it's
not and it's clear that you are power
hungry and all you want is the status
yeah you've got an ulterior motive and
it's terrifying it is it's a waving red
flag yeah it rags and it's like yeah
stuff like that is actually Bonkers
especially when it's like if someone
says like the worst thing is as well as
like yeah I've grown accustomed to this
lifestyle that pisses me off because
it's like
you you grew accustomed to my lifestyle
My Lifestyle no it's not your lifestyle
it's the lifestyle I chose to show you
yeah yeah yeah I just let you in for a
bit yeah
but I opened the doors for you you were
this is a thing because when I met you
you were broke
so why aren't you accustomed to that
life because you were broke for 24 years
and you've been Rich for 17 months so
how are you so accustomed
how did you acclimatize so quickly
you were broke for 24 years I don't get
it
I literally don't get you were broke for
years and years and years and you've
been caked for half a year yeah so how
are you so accustomed
infusing to man sign the thing explain
yourself yeah and then sign it I don't
understand second of all there's a
custom thing doesn't make sense because
if my business goes under tomorrow
you're going to get unaccustomed real
quick real quick and what you're gonna
say you're going to leave man yeah cause
you're gonna leave me
you can't you don't even want to go
broke because that's not because you're
a custom yeah yeah so if you can stand
to be broke with me you can stand up and
broke without me facts sign
literally [ __ ] sign it and then if it
is a custom thing all right but yard
yours yeah car yours bills are paid yeah
and I'm gonna give you one lump sum of
like 200k yeah deal with that as you
will you're patent that's just your
lifestyle facts Go and Do With It invest
it spend it I don't give a [ __ ] your
yard is paid for your Cosmic you don't
need to worry about [ __ ] you don't need
to worry about it and if you're only
buying Essentials that 200k is Gonna
Last for the rest of your life yeah get
a job yeah get a job like a normal
person yeah fam when I hear these
stories and they're like oh like uh what
was it Dr Dre's wife did you hear about
that one like last year or whatever uh I
just know she took bags I don't know bro
apparently he I can't remember what she
was going after let's say she was going
after like 500 mil I think it was 100
Mil he was it I think it was yeah
literally I'm pretty sure he offered her
originally I'd like a either I could be
wrong
100 or 200 mil something like that and
was like here's this and she said nah I
want half my guy
and then I think in the end she lost and
got less than what he offered in the
first place
she would have broken down in court bro
but that to me is like bewildering why
not you're saying no to a hundred not a
hundred mil you're not gonna spend it in
your lifetime
what's wrong with you some people I saw
where um I saw a tick tock of like it
was like a Judge Judy Judge Judy esque
type thing about
um it was a child child support court
something like that and it was a black
judge and I already know and this [ __ ]
said I don't work I don't bro I've seen
it multiple times rattled me yeah yeah
I've seen that rattled me she's a cow
she's a [ __ ] little moose brother it
just how how dare she say he pays for
everything I can't be asked to what and
when when the judge said oh we're gonna
take we're gonna drop the um
um what was it you said something about
Healthcare something with Healthcare
we're gonna
um subsidize the healthcare science so
your the lady is going to get a little
bit less child support he's like a
little bit less he was like less less I
brought him here to get more and she's
like well the judge was like if well if
you work you will get more it's like I
don't want to work yeah I'm not working
I'm not working I just use his pee I use
his p and I my mom owns the yard so I
don't pay rent why the [ __ ] do you think
I would work why would I work that's
foolish that doesn't pattern in my brain
like I'm getting free money
I want more free money yeah this is why
we're here I brought him here to get
more cake so I can work less
stuff like that is actually Bonkers to
me bro I've met people in my life that
are adults and haven't worked in a day
really just welfare Thing Really they
have Utes they get money they've never
worked they've actually never worked a
day in their life Wow and they never
will wow
um but at the same time sorry to cut you
off in terms of this welfare thing and
you've got you it's a blah blah is there
a point the government Cuts you off or
not yeah they never used to be that's
why you used to hear those stories where
like some a lady will have like
octuplets and she lives in like a
mansion yeah okay she'll get weekly P
for every single year she has oh a few
years ago they changed it so I think
after two years you don't get nothing
okay you get I think you get P for your
first two and then after that you're on
your own bro but you will still get pee
every year or every year for the two but
for them not child support was it called
like child maintenance or something nah
it's called like uh child tax credit or
something something like that okay child
tax benefits or something like that you
get that for the first you and the
second you and then after that yeah you
don't get nothing so any you have after
that you best pay out of your own pocket
okay
um but people used to get P for every
you they have wow and then on top of
that if you've got multiple genders they
can't after 10 years old they can't stay
in the same room so if you've got a boy
and a girl and you're getting P for both
and you're in a two bedroom yard so
they've got to share room as soon as one
of them turns ten they'll put you in a
three bedroom yard wow you're not paying
rent wow and you're getting pee for both
of them
wow oh yeah and then you can keep having
use and the more use you have as soon as
your yard is overcrowded they'll put you
in another yard four bed five bed yard
because you keep having use and you keep
getting pee for every you so there was a
point bro backwards well they used to
make documentaries about this there's a
point where people in England were just
having
9 10 11 news and they were making
Grands a month
no one's working in this yard bruv wow
no one's working they're living in a 10
bedroom house
with 10 Utes and they're making two
grand three grand a month wow and
everything's patterned they're not
paying rent they're not paying nothing
wow that's um and then the dad will have
a slip and fall yeah and they'll get a
Mobility card yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah some stuff like that is
absolutely crazy but sometimes I do
think about it like when you take when
you take the um
sometimes I like to think of things like
when you take the audacity out of it
like that [ __ ] or that courtroom yeah
when you take that audacity out if
audacity wasn't a thing yeah and you
actually listened to what she's saying
yeah sometimes it's like in fact tell me
because if you actually take it word for
yeah yeah take the pistache out of it
yeah and she's like he pays me X
why would I work yeah yeah and the judge
is like what if you get a job I'm not
getting a job because I don't need one
but it's like it's just like say sorry
to cut you off it's just like saying we
get paid Grands a month for chat and
[ __ ] on here yeah why would I now then
go and search for a nine to five yeah
why would you go work in Tesco if
someone's like it's literally it's
literally the same thing as like okay
you make this much money doing this and
you're like cool how much free time do
you have oh probably like 25 hours a
week free time and they're like well you
could get a job so why aren't you having
a job exactly yours is like why what the
[ __ ] would I yeah why would I I get bags
away yeah why the [ __ ] what why would I
get a job so yeah her her thing is like
but if I get a job I'll make this much
money because a lot this is the thing
with this is the trouble with like
Universal Credit and attack and the
welfare system in the UK especially is
that a lot of the time
when you've grown up and your mum and
dad doesn't have a job and then you've
been grown up in that that same
environment when you're an adult
you think cool and you have low you have
you have a family that doesn't respect
your education they were very low
educated so they don't respect education
so they just let you bunk of school
whenever you want yeah you've got [ __ ]
grades so your job prospects are low as
[ __ ] yeah so you're like all right bet
government pays me 1200 a month if I get
a job
for my qualifications I'll be looking at
40 hours a week and I might come up with
1300 a month basically I'm working 40
hours a week for a hundred pound a month
yeah for 20 pound a week basically
obviously I'm not going to do that yeah
but you're gonna chill I'm gonna chill
and the Boris is going to keep giving me
or Liz now this is just going to keep
running me money so why would I get a
job like I can see why if you take the
audacity out of it yeah because the all
the answer is always oh you're so lazy
you don't want to contribute but if you
just take all of that out of it and you
just take it for word for word verbatim
is a bit like
if I grew up in that culture I wouldn't
get a job either yeah it's only again
there's always people who have better
job prospects yeah it's not I doubt it's
people who are stacking freezer shelves
in Tesco and not complaining that men
are not getting jobs because they're
like this is [ __ ] because I remember
when I was in uni and I was working in
warehouses where I would make it two
weeks and that's like bottom of the bus
these are the kind of jobs that these
men that were talking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you're on Universal Credit
when you're on welfare these are the
kind of jobs that you can get yeah and
mandem out here saying man don't work in
a comfy office are like you're a lazy
[ __ ] you should get a job and then you
go out and get a job you work in a
warehouse working the night shift
and you're like this is the worst day of
my life facts and I have to do this
every day every single day for five days
and I get the same money than what I was
getting when I was chilling at yard I'm
going back home oh Rags I'm quick
oh here's your still two toe caps here's
your hive is I'm literally bouncing this
is a silly stupid idea why would I do
this I'm just gonna make fake CVS I can
just spend three hours at home fake
applying for jobs that I can't get I'm
gonna I'm gonna apply it to be a stock
broker and I'm gonna apply to be a
lawyer and they're all going to reject
me and they're going to go job center
and say look no one wants to hire me and
then I'm going to keep getting bags from
you that's it I'm gonna keep getting
bags from you so incentivize it
incentivizing yeah I know they do have
some incentive things now that they will
like um drip feed and cap so like for
example
like I think on Universal Credit like
for example if you're making x amount
say you're making 1200 a month on
Universal Credit sometimes you'll get a
job and then like your job can pay you a
grand a month and I'm like cool we're
not gonna pay you 1200 anymore we're
gonna pay you 600. so now you're coming
out with 1600 yeah now you're making 400
pound or more a month than you were
before stuff like that incentivizes
people so keep working and the more they
get and they'll be like all right now
you're making 1400 a month we're not
going to give you uh 600 a month we're
going to give you 300 pound a month but
now you're making 1700 pound a month now
we're talking money yeah now we're
talking I can level you can buy a couple
things with that now you can live a bit
comfortably yeah
yeah let's see what else you can do
let's push you a bit further yeah let's
push it harder
that's that's the way but that's the
only way a patterns yeah because
otherwise people are like this is dead
that's hilarious this is [ __ ] a good
way to think about it
um right I've got a thread hit me um and
then I've got the side now to talk about
as well cool right
ready yeah yeah so I found this thread
or someone sent me this thread yeah and
it's like you might have seen it yeah it
says the craziest thing a person has
said to you
okay I don't think I've seen it right so
craziest thing a person has said to you
I'll go first
a jet they love these these chicks they
love to use the star signs to to to to
describe the man they love to use the
star signs a Gemini yeah a Gemini man
said to me yeah months after breaking up
with me oh hang on you good yeah
right that's our [ __ ] hang on a Gemini
man said to me months after breaking up
with me I wish I got you pregnant so I'd
have a reason to see you and have access
to you for the rest of my life yeah
that's crazy
bro crazy that's a red flag I wish I'd
got you pregnant so I'd have access to
the rest of my life you will take me
back because I'm Relentless I'm not
gonna stop you know for a fact I'm here
every Saturday for the next 18 years
he's got no choice you're gonna bang me
again
relationship you get it I'm gonna ruin
it
I'm just gonna say some outlandish [ __ ]
and you're gonna just have to Scurry
back yeah literally you're gonna have no
other options sorry not sorry sorry not
sorry you should have thought that
before you let me get you pregnant a
Gemini man Gemini man she's never gonna
[ __ ] Gemini all right again right an
old friend an old friend of mine asked
me for nudes and I said no what the [ __ ]
yeah why would you ask me that he said
wow I thought I could trust you
and I don't know I just felt like I
should be able to never talk to me again
I thought I could trust you wow I
thought I could trust you what backwards
bro you manipulate little bastard you
know what never talk to me again wow
literally never talk to me again
I asked for tits and you said no where's
the trust
wow bro
some of you men are dangerous you know
what never talk to me again
after you ask me for tears right wow
that's hilarious
man said dude told me in the middle of
kissing that he's never been with a
black girl before that I was his first
one I'm clearly mixed and very light so
that made me feel weird then he goes
you're my little Jungle Girl
oh you're my little jungle guy my God
that's a fantasy for him bro he's
willing to take whatever yeah yeah yeah
he's willing to take whatever yeah he's
never seen skin like that she's never
held together man I'm one eighth I'm one
eighth black like my eyes are blue like
my hair is blonde look at me look at me
I've got two curls and a couple freckles
and I said you're my little jungle girl
[ __ ] Jesus
all right
I I told a guy I was barely dating that
I wouldn't call him daddy because that's
what I call my father
my dad died a few weeks later
when I told him he said since he's dead
you can call me Daddy
bro since he's dead you can call me
daddy now outlandish where are they
meeting these bro I don't know where are
they meeting these men
bro a Leo man said to me here we go a
Leo man said to me that lion and Leo man
said to me I'm gonna treat you so bad
you commit suicide
whoa I told you I'm no good and you
won't leave so understand this is your
fault wow
I told you I'm no good and you refuse to
leave
so this is wrong this is your fault
wow when you're trying to jump don't
look at me wow did this to yourself
wow bro that's probably the worst one
you've read bro
a Capricorn lied to me about what [ __ ]
sake
I Capricorn lie to me about what his
last name was for months when I found
out and asked him why did when I found
out and asked him why oh [ __ ] hell
when I found out and asked him why he
did that he said what I can't lie
what bro what a man can't lie
for months but for months Let Me Lie if
I want to lie where again ladies where
are you meeting these man bro that was
the last one what man can't lie
nah why do I have to tell the truth
these are the ladies that are getting
stopped in like Walmart all right
they're like looking for a young ticket
they get they get gas that again
chirpsed rags to get a few they get dick
down yeah oh yeah prison dick prison the
absolutely they ain't come like that in
a minute yeah Walmart scooped up one day
prison dick
and they're gas they're here now all of
a sudden you don't even know his last
name they're here now and you confront
him he says
I have this is America
and if I want to lie about my last name
who are you to tell me I can't this is
America
that is the funniest statement last time
I checked this is America
who are you to tell me I have to tell
you my last name
Free Speech because we're in a
relationship you need to know everything
to know about there is to know about me
America oh genius genius that's
hilarious free country now say what I
want to say
that's jokes uh you say you got a side
house for me
yeah
so
we've left it to this point but
oh this is a pretty like poignant topic
yeah so today while we're recording this
is not happening but by the time this
day releases it's Queen's funeral oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
Queen of England died
tender age of 96. tender age of 96. and
it is sent it has devices why did the
nation yeah divided it's divided the
nation
Twitter
the day she died was wild you're not on
Twitter like that no I'm not it was wild
it's one of those ones where it's it
wasn't even worth the backlash I would
get or we would get for me to read those
tweets out oh I think it's really that
bad they were bad but they were like
dark dark humor dark dark humor
I was like I saw a couple I saw a couple
um or a couple memes that made me laugh
but they weren't even dark like that
they weren't even dark like that there's
like
um I saw one was like the Undertaker you
see when like um when the Undertaker
that that uh that match where they had
to bring the Undertaker in a coffin yeah
and he was dead and then he like did the
thing and they said
the queen at the Queen's funeral when
Becca comes to pay her respects
nah sweet me [ __ ] it out [ __ ]
I find it to be a very very very
fascinating topic and I love the fact
that I've been to and fro about how I
feel and I think I've landed in a bit of
a middle ground but I find it
fascinating so
obviously she's died
she's like the longest standing Monarch
the country's ever had history and I'm
pretty sure she's like top three longest
animalics of all time yeah in the world
um and the reason it's divided the
country if you're obviously not from the
UK
um and you need a bit of context the
reasons divided the country is because
this is a very Multicultural country now
and it's not the country it was when she
became Queen
a lot of people don't give a [ __ ] about
the monarchy a lot of people find them
to be useless rich people who just live
in a tower They Don't Really contribute
to politics or laws that go on on a
day-to-day basis they kind of just go
through taking pictures and they're just
a big tourist attraction and people
foreigners who come around and tourists
who come tend to care a lot more about
the queen than people who actually live
here
um
and
a big divide is because in our
generation
like I said in our generation
we have the internet and like I said
it's very Multicultural so a lot of the
people that live in this country come
from country originally come from
countries that were colonized by England
by England by the monarchy all this
stuff and it's only even some of these
countries till now are only getting
their independence like last week yeah
that's mad like last week when Prince
William's about to go around and just
start spudding these men are like while
you're here yeah we won out and these
things are happening now and it's like
everyone's past it it's just everyone's
past it and then you've got very
traditionalist people who are getting
very very very offended by the dark
humor by the jokes and they find it
extremely disrespectful
um and then the backlash on that
is that some people are doubling down
and being like for one if you'll Vex at
me for not being upset
[ __ ] you and for two
why like why are you so upset
um and then obviously the backlash is
that is like I said you're disrespectful
does that she was there she was that she
was this and
as it was happening and I was seeing it
unravel like my typical James brain
without putting much thought into it was
like everyone needs to chill out yeah
everyone is [ __ ] children like it's
yes I understand the Queen's dead but
cool like everyone could just get on
their lives yeah I can understand why
people are making jokes because that's
just the generation we live in that is
the generation it's just the Gen it
doesn't matter who it is people made
jokes of [ __ ] uh Kobe Bryant when you
die like if it happens [ __ ] happens and
people make jokes and that is just how
our generation works yeah we just make
jokes about [ __ ]
um and it's not intended to be
disrespectful but I think the thing with
the queen is a lot of it is intended to
be disrespectful of course because of
the colonization because of that
um and the other side of it which I also
agree with is like I saw
um one brother come out the other day I
saw it on uh Instagram and was basically
saying and I agree with this thoroughly
is like jokes are jokes but the fact
that some people are actually
celebrating regardless of that the fact
who who what you think of her as a
person she's a dead person yeah and some
people are genuinely celebrating that's
[ __ ] weird like regardless of the
jokes and the tweets and all this stuff
when people are actually like enjoying
the fact that people are pissed at them
for not being upset and they use the
guise of colonizer this that
because you won't scream and colonizer
when she was alive you're just living
your life yeah you were chilling you
were just living your life you were
going to work you were tweeting all this
stuff yeah bring down the monarchy this
that went on it like that why are we
like praising these people [ __ ] the
queen I hate the queen she did this this
no one was you lot weren't saying that
before but now she's dead you'll find an
excuse to be a reactor not like you're
not responding to things you're just
reacting you're thinking this is a stir
[ __ ] and also I don't really know my
history but I heard she colonized some
[ __ ] [ __ ] her yeah and it's just it is
mad disrespectful if you're actually
happy someone is dead
obviously disrespectful yeah that's
that's that is a mass murderer that's
yeah yeah disrespectful and so I can see
it from both sides so but like I said
initially this is a bit of a run so I
apologize fine initially my thought
process was hey man
Queen said people are going to make
jokes some people need to chill out some
people are upset I don't know why you're
so upset but cool and I I started doing
some reading I started doing some like
stuff on like watching some stuff on
YouTube from people that are smarter
than me to get an understanding of it
and um it was actually a video from
Russell Brand who did like a 15 10 to 15
minute breakdown
of why people feel the way they feel
yeah and it actually was a really good
watch okay and it it put me back in the
middle I was a bit more leaning towards
the jokesters because like I said that's
just our generation yeah and I was a bit
more I'm always
not against but I'm always like I'm
never very embracing to people that deem
oversensitive because like you've never
met the queen yeah so why are you crying
like this yeah like what that stuff to
me I'm very like adverse to stuff like
that so it's hard for me to empathize on
that side yeah and it's easier for me to
empathize with the joker that's just
what that's literally what my job is
um so
and like I said it doesn't mean I'm with
people who have been like disrespectful
to the dead and stuff but I know jokes
are jokes however the way he portrayed
it in a way that I didn't think about is
that a lot of people are very affected
because it's come at for one it's come
at a time her death has come at a time
where
some may deem it so for one side of
things it's let's talk about the people
that I'm not saying for her death but
some people who are very much more
relaxed about it and aren't too fussed
about and don't necessarily it
necessarily see as a tragically a tragic
a tragedy past the fact that it's a
person dying apart past the fact that
that is a human life lost
past that tragedy
I'll talk about what he reflects on the
people on that side of the fence that
that just think all right well life goes
on it's like we're coming at a time
in our lives like I said we've got the
internet you've got a lot more exposure
as to what happens around the world
we've got a lot more understanding of
the history of the monarchy and we're at
a time where the monarchy has such
little power to do anything
[Music]
and such little contribution as well as
you've got Prince Harry's left he's he's
shacked up with a black thing and he's
dipped
um
people are on to Prince William just got
some cottage down a road and people are
like oh he's spending this much on his
kids schools he's spending this much on
that like people are actually taking
time to dive into what the [ __ ] royal
family spend their money on yeah yeah
yeah you've got home boy who
you've got Andy who's just
yeah he's he's ducking cases yeah like
we've never seen yeah he's greasing
pockets and hanging with
Island pedophiles yeah yeah so like the
whole thing is Harsh and then you've got
like old stories of like Prince Philip
who was just racist
strong strong firm racist yeah yeah
English best English all he knew was
English
bro yeah
I like my bacon crispy and my Black's
dead
that's what he said is that what he's
joking he obviously didn't
but he was a Stern racist and proud of
him I'm not gonna lie you scared me
because that video can never surface no
no of course he was Stern racist but he
was old as dick yeah when he died he was
old looking but anyway beside the point
but so to to empathize he died this year
last year
bro I get so confused ever since 2020. I
don't know what you're saying I don't
know when what happened when it must
have been this year I don't know
so to talk on those people
um
he basically said like we're at time
where the world is changing so quick and
our understanding of the power hierarchy
is for the first time where as an entire
population we're really struggling
with our understanding of
literally the hierarchy of power yeah
the monarchy being the top of it yeah
because we've gone through a pandemic
where man all of a sudden are telling
you can't leave your yacht you're going
through and all this time we've got the
internet so you this is the first time
in history where all these things are
happening and propaganda doesn't work
yeah because you can just everyone can
just see what's happening all over the
world yeah everyone knows you've been
lied to yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and you'll be misled and all these
things and like there's agendas that are
very clear to see and all this stuff so
like for the first time
in history people the general public are
questioning the power hierarchy within
their own system so uh like you said
like
the the everyday man is so blatantly
under appreciated when it comes to
politics and the law and like what it
means to be a common man a Tradesman a
postman like a policeman a a fireman all
these things like to be like a worker
for the NHS and just like you hear like
NHS is understaffed overworked the
common like people can't get on the
property ladder all this stuff and then
all you hear is tax benefits for the
rich like being self-employed is better
than being employed like people only
stay in a job for a year they just want
to update their CV so they can move move
there's no tradition so our concept of
tradition in 2022 is Warped and the
Pinnacle of tradition is literally the
royal family yeah that is the the most
Stern point of tradition in the history
of Britain Britain is the royal family
the royal family that is literally what
Britain is and at the head of that is
the queen so
now she's dead it's come at like the
Pinnacle time where everyone's
questioning what is the point of
tradition yeah you've got for the first
time
third generation Africans yeah third
generation Jamaicans third generation
Polish people Russian people Indians
um like Asians all these people are
second third generation now and they've
just got this culture yeah their
tradition is useless their parents
tradition is useful no one wants to hear
it anymore and the same thing goes with
politics and the same goes with how
people work and the jobs that they get
the concept of tradition in this country
is a breaking point we are literally one
generation away from stopping using that
word because in day-to-day science of
society tradition means nothing nothing
yeah all people do is question why do I
have to follow tradition because it's
pointless that's the world we live in
and like I said the Pinnacle of that
being the queen
she physically dies as the concept of
tradition is dying so for these
Progressive school and the progressives
the younger generation the Millennials
the the Genesis whatever
a lot of those people are like cool this
is just another example of why like
because always they see with the queen
Queen's death is cool right Prince
Charles is next King Charles now
[Music]
their next thing is who cares literally
for what though like he's gonna send to
the throne we've now got a king for what
reason
no one can answer it yeah apart from
tradition and then we're in a generation
where everyone like what's that what is
that so what these men make how much
these men make how much for just their
titles Prince William has now ascended
to like
[ __ ] Prince of Wales he's gone from a
net worth of 30 million to like 1.3
billion just from having a new title oh
yeah
people are like what are you talking
about what does he do he doesn't what
does he actually do exactly so it's come
there's literally her death is a
physical reprint representation of the
breakdown of tradition in this country
so that that's where a lot of people are
coming from the colonizing all that
stuff is like that's that's history at
the end of the day like I'm not I don't
think I'm so naive as to actually have a
physical
or emotional reaction to the history of
colonization I know what it is I know
it's happened
but it just doesn't affect me on a
day-to-day basis now so for someone to
die I mean to start bringing up
colonization when I wasn't talking about
colonization when she was alive it's a
stupid thing they don't add up yeah yeah
like it's just dumb
now the other side yeah
the people let's call them
traditionalists yeah the people who are
affected this like on a very personal
emotional level
um he did a great job of breaking down
where they're coming from from this
because it's very easy like you said
when a Nigerian mum is questioning why
you're chatting to white gal or why you
don't want to
um when someone's not understanding why
you don't want to practice Islam or why
you don't want to go church on Sundays
like
for that same reason
you've got the Traditions over here
um who are very very upset by this is
happening because the queen reigned for
like 80 years yeah so unless you're like
in your 80s yeah you won't really which
no one is we're talking about 0.1
percent of the population
so 99.9 of the population have never
taken a breath where she wasn't the
queen facts they've never breathed none
of us know what it's like to not have
the Queen Elizabeth as a queen yeah and
in a time where there's a lot of uh
feminism extreme feminism
um there's like
people talking about the patriarchy the
matriarchy we as a we as a civilization
we as a society in England uh and as a
country in Britain
have a female leader or have had forever
for a female leader because everyone has
lived bro as long as everyone has lived
yeah almost everyone is live yeah almost
everyone yeah for 99 of the people on in
in this country she has always been the
queen yeah that is it's a fact it's just
the queen yeah and then you start
thinking about
money you've seen her every day you've
ever held a piece of money you've seen
the Queen's face
every time you've posted a letter and
had a stamping you've seen the Queen's
face yeah like it's You've Got Her
Majesty's prisons Her Majesty's Royal
Mail her it's always Her Majesty Her
Majesty Her Majesty our entire culture
is based around her majesty what it is
to be British is her majesty yeah that
is what it is to be a part of this
country whether you whether you're on
the Progressive side and the
anti-tradition side or the traditional
side it's a matter of fact that every
person in this country has had some form
of connection with the queen for a for
all of their life all of their life not
even for a little part of their life
their life every day of their life
they've had some form of connection to
the queen they've seen the Queen's face
every single day of their life
and now she's dead and all of that will
change so people literally especially if
you're older 50 60 using the queen's
face for the last 60 years every day
that you've ever you've seen the Queen's
face more than you've seen your mom's
face yeah
like everything and that is gone now
we're gonna have to change the money
we're gonna have to change the names
we're gonna have to like for who Prince
Charles I don't know this guy like who
is this this is all changing this is
what is happening and then you've got
young people who on this from their
perspective now you've got young people
who are just being disrespectful just
like bro I don't think you understand
yeah yeah she's been here forever
literally she's the mother of our
country bro she's literally the mother
of our country like why are you doing
this like just chill just chill all
these tweets on this dark humans use
this like she's a colonizer she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is this it's like Yo
dude like
this is the woman I grew up with this is
the woman who would make a speech on
Christmas Day and [ __ ] like a lot of
people grew up tuning into that New Year
spiritual because I don't even know what
[ __ ] speech she does but that species
she does a lot of people turned 100 and
got a letter for the queen yeah yeah
jubilees bro have you seen London on a
jubilee day it's nuts it's a shutdown
it's a shutdown she's the only reason
anyone comes to on holiday to this
country without her no one there is no
tourism yeah in the UK without the queen
yeah
so these Traditions people off [ __ ] like
they don't know how to process this
thing
um but anyway sorry what are you gonna
say it was uh you said the Jubilee um
the 100 thing and it reminded me of one
dark humor tweet that I saw okay and
it's gonna ruin the whole thing so just
crack on just it's fine
I'm wrapping up I'm wrapping up um but
yeah it is a very very divisive moment
in the country and it's just gonna get
worse yeah because now we've got like 10
days whoa
but we've just had 10 days of mourning
and to the extasion on Instagram early
the extent that some of these morning
rituals are doing bro what have you seen
bro like some people just can't do
nothing like some people can't I saw a
sign like a bike shed or a bike lock
thing I was like you can't leave due to
morning period yeah don't leave your
bikes here otherwise they'll get like
towed they'll get taken silly that's
what you want about the world needs to
go around like I don't need everyone
still needs to know yeah bank holiday
thing yeah well yeah close everything
close everything on the Monday yeah 10
days that's a lot do we need this yeah
that's a lot so it just gets worse and
that's where jokes start coming out even
more and all this stuff but at first I
was really struggling to understand why
people were so emotionally affected by
her passing yeah but after like I said
reading some stuff listening to some
stuff watching some stuff I'm actually
like you know what I'm gonna [ __ ]
understand to be fair I I was one of
those ones that was on the on the right
side and saying that I'm not really
affected but to be fair I'm still very
indifferent because when she passed when
I found out she passed
it was like one it was bound to happen
it was expected she's she was old you
know I mean like she was 96. come on we
weren't expecting anything more for so
much longer you know respectfully yeah
yeah um
so it was I was very indifferent in the
fact that she passed away and I was very
indifferent in the fact that I knew
there was going to be jokes and I knew
there was going to be people that are
going to be mourning and take it
seriously I was just like meh but I'm
still cracking on with my daycare yeah
yeah yeah but after listening to you
um go on and describe both sides it's
understandable why like you said all our
lives all I've known is the Queen Her
Majesty there's so Majesty that seeing
the Queen's face I'm here seeing on the
stamp all this stuff like there's
nothing else but the queen yeah and it's
like like you you set a valid point was
like we now have a king but for what for
like the fact that um Wesley's face has
now gone from uh one point sub before
what 100 M's
just because he's now he's got a
different title for what yeah like
things like literally four what and
that's understandable like you can't
I don't know it's it's it's
um
it's very I think it's very tough to
um
how do I explain this
in our generation especially people of
not even necessarily just our age
probably our age and maybe just a little
bit younger maybe not like the teens of
nowadays or the Gen Z of nowadays
because they're the ones that probably
wouldn't care as much or yeah not that
I'm saying I care as much because I'm
still very like very much in the middle
um but probably Our Generation the most
because we are the ones that have seen
life pre social media pre-internet and
we're the only ones that have
transitioned into that into that phase
um
we have seen like you said propaganda is
no longer a thing we know everything for
facts yeah we know that people are
hiding certain things from us and we
just have to either be forceful and be
like you need to tell us the truth or
just crack them with our day it's
we can't
I know we can't just keep
how do I explain this
I just I just feel like it's it's it
doesn't
it just doesn't compute in the sense
that we can't just keep one one making
jokes or two just
keep mourning for like you said this 10
day thing or by the time this comes out
it won't be it will be the day it just
doesn't it just doesn't add up like we
just have to
King The King stuff doesn't make sense
bro I'm even even trying to think about
and explain it it's just racking my
brain yeah because it just doesn't it's
a very scary Breaking Point
um in which people are very confused
but there's not a specific action anyone
can do facts at this point facts so like
people can question yeah like but
where's that yeah why like what are we
doing this for but we're not at that
like Breakthrough moment where people
are like
now we're standing up and this this is
locked I don't know when we're gonna get
to that point and I don't know what's
gonna happen to you yeah yeah even when
it happens yeah
um and like
again as as technology uh changes and
people change you have stuff like Prince
Harry you have stuff like the exposure
of like prince Andrew and stuff like
that and you have all these things and
then like it just encourages more and
more because the the other thing with
the queen was
um is that
her passing is such a breakdown of
tradition because not she actually was
like the most traditional person whilst
her family is doing bogus yeah yeah she
is straight straight and narrow you
don't see her speak yeah straight and
narrow bang yeah who calm and collected
at all times bro yeah she was the
Pinnacle of what it is to be a queen
fact the Pinnacle fact you don't see I
do [ __ ] yeah apart from Wheel spinning
this rage with a vaccine yeah apart from
that
where behind the wheel you're going to
see a different Queen differently it's
just yeah she's peeling off apart from
that jokes
um she was it bro
stylistic and composed yeah facts chica
all times polite soft voice sucks and no
one's seen anything different from her
for 80 years she's never broken
character she's never broken that's been
televised she's never broken never once
no one's ever seen it so it's like so
easy to respect her but then like you
said lucky is Charles coming up because
if it was a different prayer who's been
doing up this madness yeah he's a cool
calm guy as well still it's everyone's
like
who is this brand now Charles is a shaky
brother and he's old then William's
coming up yeah luckily he's a bit
traditional as well yeah but still these
men are breaking character as we go down
the line yeah yeah yeah and by the time
Prince Williams George whatever his name
is by the time George is King it's a
rock It's A Wrap it's gonna have hoses
facts have you seen his chicken little
face
in the palace a hundred percent he's
gonna be doing Tick Tock dances on the
throne
he's probably going to change the throne
to just like swords yeah like yeah he's
gonna be talking about let's get dragons
up here yeah it's long less genetically
like modify something let's cook it up
yeah so like yeah I reckon by the time
George is up there people are gonna be
like this is so silly let's break it
down yeah let's break it all down and
spread the funds yeah yeah it's not
making sense this is some next it's not
making sense yeah so unless it's it may
be a case where it kind of uh
transitions into more of uh
it might be because it transitions into
more of like
um you know like a like a Dubai eating
like an Emirates thing where their man
have royalty Galore yeah but the rest of
the world don't know who of who the [ __ ]
any of them are um all these shakes and
all these masks no one on this side of
the world has a [ __ ] clue okay okay
yeah they're just in their palace
they're rich no one sees them no one
hears from them they do their thing
turns into that
at the same time those countries are
hardcore traditionalists those Muslim
countries they're not piping up to no
one they're just doing what they do
unless Allah tells me to different I'm
not doing different these men want to
have their palace have your Palace my
guy yeah over here we say what we want
yeah
and it's a bit sticky because like I
said by the time George is up there it's
going to be different he's gonna be mad
it's gonna be a bit mad it could be
[ __ ] enough Alice there's gonna be
hoes in the past one million percent so
yeah I don't know bro it's gonna be it's
a very very very interesting time to be
alive tradition is done it's on the
breaking point of being done yeah in
every aspect like in the families in the
workplace
um and
in the power structures of our society
all of it is breaking down and just as
that happens Liz is like I'm out I'm
done I'm out and everyone's like right
here we go there's the start snowball I
was literally snowball literally bro um
literally [ __ ] this is gonna be the
longest episode ever we've got Addy
questions to do we do have IG questions
[ __ ] now let's get first good
right guys
the
um IG question of the week is
the biggest lie you've told your parents
as per juicy and I'm just gonna bang
through them James come on then I lost
my new phone two days after my 14th
birthday I said I was held up at knife
point
that I couldn't go to church because the
pastor likes children no he said it's
your parents
but it's also one of those ones do you
believe what your child says and why is
your child saying this yeah that's the
real question why are you saying this
why is your child saying it why is my
child saying this you can be as mad as
you want yeah but you have to think of
the back of your mind why is my child
saying this what does it look like if I
drapes him to church if he's not lying
if I find out he's not lying and he told
me Mom pasta likes you I'm not going he
likes kids and she says shut the [ __ ] up
and get in the car we're going to the
Lord and then we find out in two weeks
that man's been arrested I can't look
much Social Services are coming to the
yard fat because I done told you Mom my
mom I begged you not to take me
that's a scary Eternal conflict that
really really is
that I was
that I was at Pizza Hut while I was
actually sorry I've written this so
wrong
while that I was at Pizza Hut when I was
actually being railed by the boy my
parents disapprove of
God told them that I needed a blank
check for school books but I cashed it
for weed money
my youth can never say Dad I need a
blank
school books
we're going to the school together
because if Because by the time we get
there if you're not shaking like a
[ __ ] dog bro then maybe I'll I'll
run you to check run me the magazine
team they give you and I'll take the box
because remember that thing they used to
put it in your in your book bag yeah
yeah rummit acting the subscription yeah
yeah and I'll tell you how much it is
[ __ ] a blank check
school books and you're old enough to
smoke weed what yeah backwards
I got really I got really sump burned
skiving off school and I told them the
roof came off in my defense I was high
oh my God I would beat the life amateur
how are you so sunburned the room
I was in the Sun for hours pardon my
belt is clean off my waist
bro
clean off my waist
[Laughter]
hilarious oh God that was heavy on my
period but I was aborting a child
oh
my God family
oh my God family that the pregnancy test
was my sisters they sent her back home
for a year
back home Nigeria in it family I promise
you now if I'm a female
and my sister Don said oh that's my
pregnancy and they sent me back we're
both going back oh no one's going back
someone fighting oh oh someone's dying
they sent her back for a year for a year
someone I've got a boyfriend yeah I've
got a boyfriend and social so I've got a
Social Circle it's GCSE season someone's
dying Jane
bro they sent her back home for a year
and you still didn't say nothing
you let them book the flights everything
you let me take the licks everything no
remorse night you just sat there and
said you couldn't never be my sister oh
one minute you're dead to me when I come
back you better be out the yard oh I'm
over the training
I'm over there training
bro your car ah you're just gonna see me
when I get back Kane run vastly on your
cheeks I'm ready I said arms as soon as
I touch down
jokes
told my dad that someone stole my
necklace but I sold it to pay for my
Cancun ticket no way
the more and more I read this like I'm
actually scared of having kids yo oh bro
it's terrifying because
I feel like obviously I don't know this
yet but I feel like I'll be a provider
in in all aspects for my kids life but I
feel like you can't take the piss out of
me like that because I can't be held for
my actions I would want to be the Christ
out of you I don't I look back and when
I hear stuff like that I think back to
when I was not even a kid yeah going
Cancun they're not even a kid
I took the 18 minimum there's so many
times where I took the piss yeah like I
remember
um
they've not even took the piss out of
them but just like I shouldn't be
allowed to do this yeah when I wanted to
go to iron Apple for example yeah I was
like
three 400 pounds short okay
and I was too scared to ask my parents
so I just extended my overdraft
oh [ __ ] I just took four bills out of it
and just paid off this holiday yeah yeah
and I'm in living it I shouldn't be
allowed to because I don't know what the
repercussions oh yeah I just see I'm
getting more money yeah he's giving me
free money and I'm saying yes
bro I didn't get out of that overdrive
until like two years ago
it's been a decade
I didn't know the repercussion yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so Mama should have
come with me to the bank yeah when I
opened that account yeah and they said
do you want to overdraft and she should
have slammed it said no
one million no yeah because I spent a
decade in the [ __ ] just incurring
interests long bro [ __ ] jokes all
right told my stepdad I was on holiday
meanwhile I was in rehab for mental
illness Jesus Christ first of all what
do you mean rehab for mental illness
what is that I have no idea
that I went to my friend's house for a
sleepover we went to a party instead I
was rushed to a e I was 14. oh my God
I remember
I remember like was it prom night either
prom or someone sweet 16. yeah yeah or
something yeah at one of my boys got
Twisters
it's a carry him home he was not allowed
to be drinking bro and he was paralytic
oh my I remember knocking on the door
yeah at like two in the morning yeah for
his mum to come down in her dressing
gown I've never heard someone so angry
drapes this collar closed the door and
all you can hear is get the [ __ ]
upstairs you [ __ ] Dicker get a [ __ ]
up I was like yeah oh oh I'm so happy
I've never been in that state especially
when I was younger I remember I've told
you before I tried to sneak in my yard
at five before in it after a party yeah
yeah
you give me a break
um Social Circle
or get back at like yeah or I'm like
ruining my issue with my mom yeah
because she's gonna be so livid yeah all
my boys think I'm a [ __ ] yeah I'd
rather ruin my relationship I've got a
pie that starts at half ten and be home
for 11. it doesn't make it's a waste man
thing yeah that's a waste mountain and
then I also can't not go to the party
because I've got no excuse yeah facts
I've been out with my bedrooms all day
yeah and they're saying are we going to
this party what's my excuse for going
home yeah please tell me because they
came to the yard yeah when I had to go
home for dinner and they heard you say I
could go to the party they heard you say
it
they didn't hear you say be back at 11
yeah I begged my mum mum please please
please please please not 11. yeah the
Ting's that's a half ten yeah she was
like that's your business if it starts a
half ten who starts to party at half ten
everyone everyone in this day and age
everyone and it starts at half ten
people ain't touching until 12. oh [ __ ]
mom I can't come home 11. she was like
right half a level
because I remember I was sitting on the
sofa everyone's vibing I was like I
looked at the time and it was like
quarter to 12 yeah so I've already taken
a piss but I was like I can get away
with it yeah yeah yeah I was like ah
right time to go I stood up one girl sat
on my lap
and she was like where are you going and
I was like ah I'm just gonna go home
yeah she was like why the [ __ ] would you
go home yeah 16 year old me I'm like I
don't know yeah I don't have an answer
and I can't tell you my mum said I need
to be home yeah I'm 16. yeah I'm a grown
man I'm a grown-up
my mustache is in full swing I'm a grown
ass man I'm a grown ass man with a
grown-ass dick
there's no way I could say my mom said I
need to be wrong for 11 30.
bro jokes one thing that's whenever I
got home a few strong bows later I
stumbled over five as my mom's going to
the toilet
worst what the [ __ ] odds timing ever
she made me I think I said before she
missed the awake all night
I've had my first shift and my part-time
job the next day at 4 P.M 4 P.M I'm
going at 5am James I promise my mum
could she could tell she could scream
all she wants you're staying up all
night I'm going to bed bro I was laying
on my bed asleep and she would get in
there and say wake the [ __ ] up
all day the next day wake the [ __ ] up if
you're tired that's your [ __ ]
business wake the [ __ ] I told you to
come up yeah yeah you should have got a
full night's sleep from half 11 for your
first day yeah all afternoon but no look
at you now look at you now I was not
good how did the shift at work terribly
terribly I hated it it was only four
hours as well [ __ ] hating groggy boy
you must have got home and crashed bro
oh bed I think it literally lasted from
it was from half four till half eight
got home for like quarter past uh no
like quarter to nine because they're
like down the road bed didn't chat to no
one looked at my mum she looked at me
like this
she was watching TV I remember because
you can open my door and there's a
hallway in front yeah and you can just
see through the doorway yeah into the
living room my mom's so far is there I'd
open the door
turned around closed the door like
facing the door
turned around went to like step up the
stairs which are here looked in the
living room my mom's looking at me like
that dressing gown yeah cigarettes yeah
didn't small just look too loud
look straight back Coronation Street
when I walked upstairs and you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] perfect you're saying [ __ ] know
what I'm going through you don't even
know
he stopped in your bed punching people
and then you hear the spring yeah she's
like what's that he just lay down
yeah
oh I hated being a teenager oh God being
a teenager [ __ ] that's hilarious all
right
biggest lie you've told your parents
my mum wouldn't let me go to a house
party so I told her it was a last day of
chemo celebration what
what who's got cancer
that's the first thing I'm asking Mama
would never let me get away with that
there's no way in hell you've got a
bridge that's got cancer and I didn't
know about it and I didn't know about it
until today I made it through
the last day of chemo they've made it
through and I'm only hearing about today
nah you're a liar you're a chemo I'm
dropping you off there yeah show me run
me the address show me yeah if I don't
see a bald head
if I don't see gray skin in a border and
Banners yeah
[Laughter]
I don't want to go I don't want to go I
don't want to go I don't want to go I
don't want to go what time he's getting
there
I don't know what time he's getting
there
just some baby powder
wow
wow Jesus Christ
under your parents roof what are we
doing these lot do what they want they
what they want
I don't know wait that I don't know why
their tires are flat I let the air out
in case they came after me whilst I
snuck out
yeah bro that's the funny [ __ ] that is
the funniest [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] to know [ __ ] enough
that's so funny oh my God
that I'm on a night shift whilst I was
on a sneaky link with my mom's work
colleague
wow juicy wow
that the carpet burns on my knees was
from tripping up the stairs
yuck
slopping that I found a wallet with 5K
meanwhile I was selling that cocoa
well I can't imagine my dad saying
where's his five grand theft where's
this 5K he's got five grand in cash
where's it come from the wallet how big
was this one it must have been wow
five bags
oh
told her I was walking funny no told her
I was walking funny and my neck was
bruised because I was in a fight last
night
walking funny
why yoy
she got pie she got that caramel Convoy
spin that back oh my days
it wasn't my sticky stick on the
underside of the toilet seat
yuck undecided how
fam man put this thing I just knighted
Knight and closed it
disgraceful disgraceful oh my God
that I was at my bbf's my BBFS that was
at my BFFs these times I was with my
sneaky link and he had a knife to my
throat what
what
is that Kink play how did she Rose dot
dot trauma oh he went out he went it
went South
Jesus and knifed my throat
hold on thinking mama don't even know
I'm here
my mom don't even know I'm here that's
exactly I'm gonna die he's making the
face will make it exactly the face she
made help me there's no way out
because if I tell her where I am I'll go
home to a knife to myself
she'll tell man to kill me
oh told them I was up told them I was at
a friend but I was recording a sex tape
with two guys for PornHub
Jesus Christ man I helped her I helped
them look for the knife I was hiding in
my room
this is ridiculous this is actually
getting ridiculous it's not a vibrator I
found one of those big pencils from
primary school and kept it for nostalgia
bro yes I do it wasn't a vibrator that's
jokes oh Jesus last one
that I thought the condoms I bought were
water balloons and picked them up by
mistake
Christ almighty Bro [ __ ] you know but
yeah it's funny that was the question
today guys right this must be the
longest episode we've ever done yes this
must be the longest episode we've ever
done we're giving you back to back long
yeah we're going for the marathon yeah
yeah all right guys thank you so much if
you're still here thank you so much we
appreciate you we love you um head on
over to patreon.com
get your bonus episodes get your extra
content join the cult babies you're good
for good and as always guys love love
[Music]
foreign